hey guys how's it going Wow it's been a
little while huh it's good to see you
all again I am currently studying for an
exam and I took a study break and I
figured I would update you guys on
what's really going on I told myself I
was gonna get a video out this weekend I
said I'm gonna do the tutorial and I did
I started to work on it no lie I got my
stuff over here see those are all the
little ninja star parts and I even you
know made this one I also ordered some
new puzzles I got the V Cube - and I got
the V Cube to be and I also bought a new
seven it's just really hard to get the
time into the tutorial that I'd really
like to get so I was thinking of some
things and I know that everyone wants to
see the double sided you know whatever
it's called I think we're just gonna go
with double min your star I have that in
the beginning of tutorials I started the
dist:8 the double interlocked single
sided transforming eight-pointed ninja
star I think we're just gonna go with
double ninja star instead anyway I had
something else that I wanted you guys to
see I figured because Valentine's Day is
coming up a lot of you would like to see
that have had some requests for it
so I need your help I want you guys to
leave me a comment below telling me
whether or not you'd rather see this or
if you'd rather see the double ninja
star so I'm gonna leave it up to you
guys
it's a comment below highest-rated
comment is the tutorial I'm going to do
next whenever that is you know hopefully
in the next week or so oh one more thing
Leela's doing great she's right here
actually if you want to see her be like
what are you doing are you waiting to be
fed huh all right you know let me give
you a treat come here come on come in
all right Sean we look ahead sit all
right sit good girl okay
well I must get back to studying now oh
you've never seen me with glasses on
have you yes that is what I wear when I
study because I tend to squint at this
computer screen like this thank you very
much for watching I hope you're all
doing well enjoying your Sunday and oh
look at Lila she's so comfortable in
front of her little heat dish it's like
a toaster without a cover check that
thing out
you like that Lila huh I got a hungry
Kitty behind me waiting to be fed so see
ya